ce qui vous fait un total de 12 euros et
88 centimes
ah non moi j'ai 12 euros 85 centimes on
n'a qu'à tours compte et non c'est plus
prudent
allez c'est tromper ça va ça arrive à
tout le monde de se tromper oui voilà
les chansons incroyable fin 2006 c'est
toujours aussi radin non pas du tout je
te rappelle que tu m'a largué la veille
de mon anniversaire pour va m'offrir de
cadeaux une coïncidence comme j'ai sur
mon compte déjà 2 148 1596 euros un
choix c'est ce que vous faites déjà des
économies
je peux faire mieux garder votre bus ce
qu'on paie en impôts locaux je le
prendrais quand ce sera gratuit
c'est bon ça vous dirait de aller voir
la wii
il m'a invité à dîner non à quoi quand
même et oublie pas troubler le double en
une assiette depuis le petit peu trop
une assiette ou les fêtes à l'unité du
boulot je suis votre fille
pourquoi tu vas rien dit je vous dis que
lui discours que son père est la plus
grande pince du monde je ne peux pas
vous loger 100 euros par semaine c'est
gentil mais 140 ha oui comment
dis donc tu serais pas un peu un peu
quoi
bahreïn koulou oui un peu oui
pourquoi je débarque comme ça qu'est ce
qu'elle veut être simplement apprendre à
mieux vous connaître
peut être quand même bien naïf un pourra
manquer broadfoot nan mais c'est divin
mais je cana moi c'est pas grave je
finirai chez vous qui ne connaissaient
pas le deviner